start selling if you want to have
success as an entrepreneur go out there
and start talking to people start
talking to customers and start selling
it's important to have a plan but don't
have a fear of having the perfect plan
not having that perfect plan and because
you don't have it you don't actually go
out and get started hi I'm Evan
Carmichael I believe that hungry
entrepreneurs deserve help and today
maintain a question from a YouTube
viewer butta butta butta 2234 thanks to
the question Rohtang high i mean i'm
making a line of all natural facial and
body products i'll be making it myself i
planted people that sample my product
and would like to buy but i wanted to
know what are the correct steps I should
take to become a successful business hey
this is great i love this business idea
you're starting at yourself you're
bootstrapping it you're hustling you're
getting people sampling and you have
people who want to buy your next step
start selling these people want to buy
you go out and start selling this stuff
to them it's going to have a big plan
and i'm not saying go out and and just
go out without having any kind of plan
but your plan changes as you start
talking to customers the best way to
build a business is to start making
money and build a business around your
customers if you have already built a
product on your own and you have people
who have sampled it and they love it and
they want to buy you've done most of the
hard work and they say hey I want to buy
this you should be saying thank you very
much take their money and give them the
product let them use it let them love it
let them tell their friends about you
and then you can worry about the growth
the first step is getting past survival
the first step is making sure you have
enough money so that you don't have to
go out and get a job it does not
glamorous doesn't have to be a ton of
money I don't know how much you need to
survive month to month to put food on
the table pay your electricity bill pay
your rent all that stuff if you can get
to that point from selling to your
friends and family and their friends and
their family that's your first step and
then you can worry about the growth if
you're going to build new product if
you're going to go into retail stores if
you're going to sell it online or
whatever let your customers take you
there if you have people who were paying
you money and they're loving your
and they're telling your friends this is
the right step to build your business my
first thing for you would be start
selling to these guys start taking their
money give them awesome service proudly
stand behind your product try to get to
the point where you have enough money so
you can survive and not have to work for
somebody else and then worry about your
huge growth I love having a big picture
if there's a big goal you have if you
want to get into macy's or
Bloomingdale's or whatever it is you
want to sell a building products
whatever your big goal is have that in
mind use that to keep you motivated to
fuel you to get you up every day to go
out and sell your product but your very
first step where you are now try to get
to the point of survival make sure you
can pay your bills put food on the table
so you don't have to go and get a job
and if you have paying customers who are
willing and able to buy from you you're
ahead of most entrepreneurs who are just
getting started so good luck and I want
to hear about your progress and as you
grow keep me posted and if you have more
questions let me know those are you
watching like this video please give it
a thumbs up and I want to hear from you
if you like this video let me know what
you think leave a comment under the
video and if you have a question for
your own business please leave a comment
below I love sinos come in that's where
a lot of the content for this channel
comes from and it makes my morning every
time I see comments come in on the
YouTube channel so thank you guys and
I'll see you soon
you